in the first round of the competition
Prasad came up against another
exceptional Indian the brilliant from
London
what will front of house manager Dibner
think of their chat now to hear what my
experts made a push on starter I quite
like the adventures task them trying to
put the hot samosa inside the garnish
it's the joy of pressure is that they
are very comfortable with in their own
boundaries and you know weaving some
fantastic food up in Bradford ok go
please lay down well done well done well
done well done
starters finished I need to taste both
dishes stars chat nice but that heat
have nice sweet tamarind flavor I like
the hot samosa running through but it's
got that balance between the sweet
savory and the heat there as well
very good risotto of new potatoes only
these guys would turn the taters into
granules of rice
it's very rich for the sets you're gonna
need two or three mouthfuls of it so
it's not like a proper risotto
however be clever if there's one
criticism on that which is just a touch
too salty - very interesting starters
right now which one to prefer out of
those two what I have to say Prasad